- Okay.
What episode is it?
(hip hop music)
♫ Me and Gary V up in the office
♫ Do rap zapping wanting do corporate
♫ Talks about all the shipping leverage
♫ 1,800 checks, check out the average.
Life's about alternatives like,
like everybody who watches this like
when they leave comments,
like when you leave
fuckin' comments like, blah, blah, blah,
okay cool, what's the alternative?
Don't tell me blah, blah, blah,
tell me what the fuck
else is the other option.
Like don't be optimistic, be pessimistic.
You know, don't think it's true, great,
be cynical, don't wanna work hard,
great, don't work hard.
Like don't tell me I'm wrong,
don't judge, like what's the alternatives?
Like for me what's fun is I'm documenting,
I'm not creating.
Like I don't do Daily Vee.
My job is not Gary V.
I fuckin' work.
Like I'm moving, I'm doing,
I'm letting my actions speak.
(hip hop music)
- How would you tell somebody to find
their main focus?
'Cause sometimes it seems
like there's so much.
- There's nothing, think
about this question.
I tell them.
Right, it's like how do you
tell somebody to be in shape
like this dude?
You put in the work, right?
Like, hey, do sit ups, eat well,
like it's so crazy.
Everything's very basic.
It just comes down to
do you do it, or not.
I think the reason my content resonates is
I never waver, right?
Like I think a lot of you know,
after a little while,
you get the gist of what I'm about.
And then only the reason I think
I'm worth listening to after
you figured that part out,
is I'm good at trend spotting,
and if you listen to me and watch me,
you can pick up things you can do
that will make your life better.
But it only takes you
about, if you're smart,
it takes you about 30 days to realize,
I'm gonna say the same, I'm literally
gonna say the same shit
for the next 50 years.
I mean, the motivational thing is real,
but I think you can get
that at other places.
There's plenty of Instagram
accounts that say, "Go do it".
I think the fact that
I'm actually doing it,
and I don't want anything from you
is a powerful relationship point,
but then I think the longevity comes
in that I'm gonna do this around AR,
NVR, and 10 other things that I don't
even know are coming.
And I think, I didn't, Alexa's skills
and podcasts were around a year ago.
They were around.
I wasn't interested 'cause I didn't feel
the movement in the market.
Now I do.
And I think if I leave you with anything,
like whatever you wanna do in your life,
it's super important to
watch what I'm doing.
I have like a really long track record
of being successful on
land-grabbing early,
and getting disproportionate value of it.
And so you can apply that to yourselves.
(pop music)
♫ Acting on your best behavior
♫ Turn your back on mother nature
♫ Everybody wants to rule the
Which is why I don't like
the current state of
entrepreneurship in the world.
Because it seems very
party and popular and cool,
and it is literally everything but.
I started my daily vlog,
yes, I like attention and I want selfies,
but much more because I want people
to see how hard it really is.
How long every day is.
If you really wanna be successful.
And so,
I'm scared of everything,
which actually ironically
means I'm scared of nothing.
- Right, that is--
- Do you understand?
- Yeah, I get it.
- It's like, got it?
I know it's a funny little statement,
but by accepting fear of everything,
it kind of makes me numb
and makes me not fear anything.
- Anything, yeah.
That's awesome, more questions, guys.
(audience applauds)
See you off stage.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- [Cameraman] Go here Gary.
(pop music)
- Here are the things
I've learned at Rise 2017.
Gary V likes air quoting,
and the word, "Arbitrage".
(group laughs)
(audience applauds)
- [Host] Before I introduce Gary V.
(mumbles).
He needs no introduction,
please welcome the social
juggernaut himself,
Mr Gary Vaynerchuck.
(audience cheers)
- First of all, thank you
guys so much for coming.
It's awesome to be here.
I think everybody here
if I told them "everything
is gonna be okay,
"You can have everything you want,
"now, what are you
gonna do with your day?"
I think a lot of people know.
It could be anything.
If you were to then watch movies all day,
like if we played this game,
and you're like, okay, everything?
Well fuck, I don't wanna do
shit, I just wanna watch movies.
Cool, I think you should
build a business around that.
(interviewer laughs)
Right, like to me, great.
So I think people are scared.
I think people are scared.
I think people are scared
what people will think,
and I think they're scared
that they can't survive
living the life that they wanna live
from a materialistic standpoint.
What makes me so dangerous
is that I don't need anything.
I don't need anything,
I don't need anybody,
and that's it, and so I'm good.
And I wish that on everybody.
You know how nice it is to not
rely on anybody for anything at all, ever?
Not emotionally, not financially,
it's just a zen zone.
But purpose is to make yourself happy.
No regrets.
You're welcome, good bye
- Hi, Gary!
- Hey, good to see you, yes, we're coming.
- Hey Gary.
- Thanks again, Patrick.
This guy is here.
Pleasure.
- [Man] Let's go.
- You know what, I got the
budget to hire someone,
and I'm struggling if I
hire someone for ecommerce,
or someone like a guy, a guy with me.
- I would hire somebody
for sales or ecommerce.
Because that will get bigger return,
that will get more return quickly,
which will then allow you
to afford the next thing.
If you go with D-Rock and go branding,
you're gonna have to wait.
- Correct.
- Got it?
- And you know I'm for sales actually,
I'm good for product design.
Is that true I need to focus on something
I'm bad at, and try to improve?
- [Gary] No, nope.
- Because I hate Photoshop,
I hate this stuff.
- [Gary] No.
- Okay cool.
- Hire somebody for that.
- Right, all right man.
Welcome to Hong Kong.
- [Gary] Thank you, my friend.
- Gary, I will see you in like one hour.
- [Gary] See you soon.
- Thank you for everything.
- [Gary] Bye thank you, bye.
- See you guys.
- Bye everyone, bye bye.
(pop music)
The obstacle right now that I'm pissed
that nobody takes me up
on my open door policy.
So I'm gonna react to it,
and I'm gonna force every employee
to see me every six months,
period, end of story.
I will see them all.
- [Interviewer] Every employee?
- That's right.
- [Interviewer] That's New York, London?
- Whatever it takes.
I will give up all the time,
I'm gonna give up five minutes,
five minutes, times 800, lots of minutes.
- [Interviewer] Why do you think it is?
You think, you mentioned people are--
- I think they have empathy for me,
and they think I have better things to do
than hear their five minutes of headaches.
I don't think they realize that
I wanna fix every problem.
I think they think I'm like every other
one of their managers in the building
that can't fix every problem,
so they don't wanna hear it.
I can fix them all.
And then other, and then I think cynicism
and fear and lack of self-esteem,
and they think I care
more about being Gary V
than Gary Vaynerchuck to see you,
there's a million reasons.
I don't care what the reasons are.
I need to fix my concept.
That's the adversity,
that will make me better,
and that happens every single day.
Awesome.
Thank you, good luck to you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you
so much, I appreciate it.
- We're gonna go that way, okay?
- When, now?
- That way?
- [Cameraman] Yeah.
- Okay, go.
- Awesome, nice meeting you.
- Can I have a picture
as well, oops, sorry.
- I can really relate to
what you say, it's amazing.
(pop music)
- It's true.
Okay.
What episode is it?
Do you wanna pick up the camera now
and show two of our three or four homies
that help us, say hello guys.
- Hello, how are you, everyone?
- Hello.
- Vaynur-Nation, what's up?
(laughs)
- These are our two amazing teammates.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Cool.
- [Cameraman] Do you wanna do a
thanks for watching, subscribe?
- No, not really.
Sorry, thank you for asking.
Daniello, I'm very upset
because you're not with us,
and I fully expected you to be here.
First of all I hear you're
a badass entrepreneur,
so I can't wait to meet you.
Look how smiley your partner is.
(laughs)
Can't wait to meet, keep grinding,
keep hustling, but most importantly,
recognize how hardcore
of a winner you are,
and deploy that confidence from a day
in and day out standpoint.
See ya.
(pop music)
♫ I can see you hiding all the scars
♫ Wearing a facade
♫ Not meaning to offend
♫ But girl you can't pretend
♫ No, no
♫ I never see you
♫ Trying to reach out
connecting with your heart
♫ Not meaning to lament
♫ But girl you can't pretend
♫ No, no
♫ I ain't gonna tell you lies
♫ Feed you porkie pies
♫ I can tell you once I can tell you twice
♫ You never learn
♫ When will you ever learn
Thank you so much.
(laughs)
Thank you.
- You're awesome, I loved it.
- Thank you brother.
- Your line is fucking amazing.
- Thank you, brother, thank you.
- No, it's really good.
- Thank you.
- Inviting others, I know
you stopped them for a while.
- Then I started investing,
and then what happened was I invested
in Twitter and Facebook and a lot of
crazy things started happening,
and now I run a very
large social media agency,
800 people.
But the family still owns the business.
- Okay, why you don't do any more videos?
- I haven't done videos.
You know, five years every day.
- (laughs) It's a lot.
- It was a run.
- Awesome, nice to meet you buddy.
- Thank you.
Thank you for recognizing
me and thanks for watching.
- That's awesome, it's a great show.
- Thank you.
- This one over here.
Hello.
- [Table] Hello!
- [Gordon] I'm Gordon.
- [Gary] Gordon, how are you, Gary.
- [Gordon] Nice to meet you.
- Hey, nice to meet you, Jason.
- Jason, such a pleasure.
- [Lady In Black] Gary, it's not your
first time in Hong Kong?
- It's my first time.
No, it's even better, it's
my first time in Asia.
- [Table] Oh!
- Oh, is it?
- [Blonde Lady] And not the last one, no?
- No, not at all.
Yeah, you know, a mix of serendipity
and just focusing on the proper timing
and making every second count,
I've been really looking forward to it,
and it's been, it's been so pent up
that when we landed, in baggage claim,
we weren't even out of baggage claim
and I looked at D Rock, this is,
I'm gonna like this place.
(group laughs)
It's been such a remarkable
two and a half days,
like I can't wait to come back.
The level of gratitude
for entrepreneurship
and what it's done for me and my family,
the energy in this marketplace,
and in this region in general
I think I associate more
a little bit even more
than I would say than I
would associate with the US,
and definitely Europe's version of it.
So, that, yeah.
I mean, I grew up in the wine business,
I've spent a lot of time in Europe.
The rawness to the entrepreneurial spirit
is intoxicating for me.
And so,
I would say that's probably a thing
that stood out the most.
And I'll tell you another thing,
and, I am quite passionate around
having really important conversations
with young entrepreneurs
around family dynamics.
And I think one of the things I'm
most excited about, obviously so much
of my strategy in coming to Asia
is leading with my content first.
I think I'm gonna be able to help
a lot of kids have difficult conversations
with their parents that in a 50 year macro
will be enormously beneficial,
but because there's a lot of pressure
in the Asian ecosystem around education
or doing the right thing,
and I'm very empathetic to that.
My great moment of my life,
I would actually argue is
the fact that even
though I was an immigrant
in the US my mom had enough self-esteem
to support me being a bad student,
which became the foundation of my success.
- [Blonde Lady] Unconditional love.
- Unconditional love,
and really predicated on
enormous self-confidence
in my mom that she knew what
she was doing parenting,
and didn't need to follow the blueprint.
'Cause a lot of this has
to do with insecurities
of the parents.
So yeah, some interesting
things I picked up on already.
- When you say the rawness,
what do you mean by that?
- I think a little bit of a level of
a chip on your shoulder,
great wild wild west
slam grab opportunity,
maybe even an inch or two of like
doing it at all costs.
A little less polish,
a little less process.
Results-oriented.
One of the things that was fearful
is an admiration of
Silicon Valley culture,
which I think over time is
a negative for the region.
Because then you start building financial
arbitrage machines, not actual businesses.
So yeah, just a little bit more of a,
like just generally a little bit more
of a go-to attitude.
Yeah, like the questions, the tonality,
even the way I'm being pitched.
And you know what's interesting?
What I'm trying to figure out is
is there a chip on the shoulder
to a US Silicon Valley-centric thing,
which I think there should be
in a place where, especially when you look
at mainland China, you
know, those companies,
they're so much further
ahead in a lot of ways
because of their full integration.
I don't know, there's just,
there's a clearly different tone,
which my early intuition leads to
good, with my other intuition which is
there's too much looking at other places,
and it should get, I think Asia should
get more insular, 'cause
I think the natural
behaviors are better.
- Right, right.
(pop music)
♫ Think back through your life
♫ Think of all those guys
♫ Ready did they try to commit their time
♫ 'Cause you never learn
♫ Girl I wish you learned
♫ But no, no
- It used to be, still is actually,
a very influential wine bottle.
- Wow.
- [Lady] Oh wow.
- It's a small technical mouthful,
because most people love the (mumbles).
- Thank you.
- [Man] This is so good.
(table applauds)
(pop music)
♫ I know it's hard to
♫ Face up to the facts
♫ But you must react
♫ Just 'cause you've learned to wait
♫ That doesn't mean you changed
♫ No, no.